no dijo
el fútbol es como las salchichas si de
verdad te gusta es mejor no saber cómo
se hace
efectivamente este mes empieza la
eurocopa 2016 y con ella millones de
personas sacarán el cuñado que llevan
dentro para decir que no sola la
camiseta con lo que gana parece mentira
pasará hambre cabrones lo cierto es que
el fútbol mueve millones de euros el
sueldo de gente como cristiano ronaldo o
messi dejaría ana patricia botín la
presidenta del banco santander a la
altura de una pobre mileurista y de
dónde viene todo este dinero pues
principalmente de la publicidad empresas
como adidas pagan en la friolera de 43
millones de euros al real madrid'
solamente para que ponga su logotipo en
las camisetas de los jugadores y os
preguntaréis pero de verdad merece la
pena gastarse tantísimo dinero en tu
logotipo aparezca en un estadio o en una
camiseta
la respuesta os va a dejar helados
porque una consultora de marketing que
se llama radio one ha hecho una encuesta
en la que han preguntado a mil
británicos si reconocían los logotipos
de los sponsors de la eurocopa es decir
les ponían varios logos de empresas y
les preguntaban si sabían reconocer
cuáles estaban patrocinando la eurocopa
orange high sense hoy en día todos ellos
patrocinadores oficiales fueron
reconocidos únicamente por un 1% de la
gente pero la cosa no se queda aquí
porque si seguimos leyendo la noticia
encontramos cosas como esta mastercard
heineken barclays y budweiser pese a no
ser patrocinadores estuvieron entre las
10 marcas más reconocidas o sea que
hyundai ha pagado una millonada para que
luego el mérito se lo lleve heineken sin
pagar un duro bienvenidos al mundo de la
publicidad sin embargo y pese a todo
esto las empresas siguen invirtiendo
muchísimo dinero en patrocinios
deportivos de hecho la uefa va a sacar
un beneficio por patrocinios dos veces
mayor en esta eurocopa que en la del año
2012 y os preguntaréis qué hacemos en
visual política hablando de fútbol qué
tiene que ver el fútbol con la política
pues mis queridos amigos mucho tiene
mucho que ver de hecho la lista de
patrocinadores de esta eurocopa es el
lienzo perfecto para entender dónde está
la economía mundial
hoy en día mira esta es la lista de
sponsors oficiales de este año y aquí al
lado he puesto la del año 1996 es decir
hace dos décadas notáis alguna
diferencia bueno antes de ver las
diferencias vamos a ver los parecidos
porque en ambos casos encontramos
los lobos el de mcdonald's y el de
cocacola son dos empresas que llevan
años patrocinando todo lo patrocina bleu
que siempre están ahí y que tienen muy
buena salud son algo así como el jordi
hurtado de la economía pero hasta aquí
los parecidos
ahora vamos a las diferencias porque si
os dais cuenta en el año 96 había tres
empresas japonesas que patrocinaban la
eurocopa en aquella época
japón era una potencia industrial que le
estaba haciendo la competencia al
mismísimo eeuu sin embargo hoy las
empresas niponas han desaparecido del
mapa de los patrocinios y coincide con
que la última década el crecimiento
económico de japón se ha estancado
por supuesto que japón sigue siendo un
país rico con empresas muy potentes ahí
estas son y ahí está toyota pero todas
ellas fueron creadas en los años 70 80 y
casi no han innovado desde entonces por
ejemplo los primeros modelos de
smartphones fueron la blackberry y el
iphone luego llegó sony y sacó su propia
versión con tecnología punta y de muy
buena calidad pero que va a rebufo de lo
que han creado los americanos en este
caso y si os dais cuenta casi todas las
empresas japonesas están yendo a rebufo
de otras no lideran es más conocéis
algún o alguna empresa japonesa famosa
que se haya creado en los últimos años
todo esto tiene su reflejo en las
figuras macroeconómicas y por supuesto
también en la eurocopa pero vamos a
volver a la lista de patrocinadores
porque si bien japón se ha marchado han
aparecido otros distintos como corea del
sur china turquía y azerbaiyán socar es
la petrolera del gobierno de azerbaiyán
un país que casi nadie seríamos capaces
de colocar en un mapa que tiene 10
millones de habitantes y un montón de
gas y de petróleo llevan varios años
negociando con la unión europea la
construcción de un gasoducto que iría
por aquí
en principio la idea es muy buena para
los europeos porque tendríamos otro
proveedor de gas que reduciría nuestra
dependencia de países como rusia o
argelia problema que azerbaiyán es una
de las dictaduras más salvajes del mundo
no sólo persiguen a los que critican al
gobierno sino que también meten en la
cárcel a sus familiares en junio de 2015
la policía arrestó a tres familiares de
cani matzá hits un periodista en el
exilio que dirige una televisión en
turquía la dictadura de azerbaiyán
necesita lavar su imagen de cara a la
opinión pública europea y qué mejor
manera de hacerlo que financiando el
fútbol por eso hace años veíamos el
logotipo de azerbaiyán en las camisetas
del atlético de madrid y ahora nos vamos
a cansar de ver el logotipo de socar en
todas partes durante la eurocopa 2016
pero esperad porque todavía tenemos
logotipos más interesantes
ahí está el de turkish airlines nos
hemos acostumbrado ya a ver anuncios de
turkish airlines por todas partes tanto
que ya nos hemos olvidado de lo que
significa pero imaginaros que hace 20
años nos hubieran dicho que una empresa
turca va a ser una de las aerolíneas más
importantes del mundo en el año 2003
turkish airlines era una héroe
sin pena ni gloria que no la conocía
nadie diez años más tarde ganaba el
doble de dinero que iberia y es el
mascarón de proa de un país que se está
convirtiendo en la china de europa pero
sin duda alguna el logotipo más
interesante de todos es éste el de high
sense probablemente en muy poquitos
conozcáis a high sense pero muchos de
vosotros tengáis algún televisor de
ellos y no lo sepáis aysén nació como un
mero suministrador de componentes para
otros fabricantes tan conocidos como
hitachi usar durante años este tipo de
empresas al carecer de marca propia no
tenían que invertir grandes sumas de
dinero en publicidad ni preocuparse del
cliente minorista básicamente pasaban su
valor en fabricar componentes para otras
compañías por eso muchos de los routers
y de los módems que nos regalaba
telefónica y vodafone en españa estamos
fabricados por huawei pero el logo ni
siquiera aparecía en la caja lo que
tenías que abrir el cacharro y verde en
todo estaba en pequeñito hecho por
huawei sin embargo con el tiempo se han
dado cuenta de que también pueden
competir ofreciendo productos de calidad
y diferenciados la pionera en esta
tendencia fue huawei que ya lleva años
sacando móviles con su propia marca
buenos anuncios
y parece que hai sense que está
siguiendo la misma estela
y
esto no es ninguna tontería y marca un
antes y un después en la economía china
hasta ahora les veíamos como fabricantes
de productos cutres pero muy baratos
ahora están entrando a sacar bienes de
muy alta calidad con su propia marca y
por supuesto su propia publicidad en el
futuro vamos a ver muchas más empresas
chinas inundando los mercados europeos
por eso el hecho de que high sense esté
patrocinando la eurocopa significa que
se lo están tomando muy en serio
perspectiva el fútbol nos ofrece una
foto fija de lo que es la globalización
hoy en día hace 20 años el mercado
estaba dominado por eeuu europa y japón
ahora hay nuevos países como china o
turquía que están compitiendo en
igualdad de condiciones con las empresas
americanas así que la pregunta es cómo
será la lista de patrocinadores de la
eurocopa del 2036 veremos ya alguna
empresa africana podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios como
siempre lo que queráis profundizar más
en este tema encontrareis varios links
en la descripción y si os ha gustado
este vídeo darle al like y suscribiros
al canal si todavía no lo habéis hecho
nos vemos en el próximo vídeo un abrazo
y hasta pronto